developer against perkinston last
Wednesday we released a new version of
Minecraft designed specifically for
Windows 10 the Windows 10 edition is a
beta and we will get better and better
over time with the help of your feedback
all existing players or the current Java
version will get the game for free by
logging into the Mojang account and one
other thing we love about the minecraft
is the compassion the community has for
the game we look forward to bringing a
steady stream of updates and happy
manaman new things to play with this
fall thank you for playing Minecraft and
sharing your feedback with us there is
one more thing I want to share I may be
the lead available minecraft but I've
also been working with my close to a
mycosis friend Daniel and Ponder's on a
new game called cobalt with cobalt we
wanted to build something that we could
play together with great couch
multiplayer and a fun co-op multiple
adventure game now I'm excited to share
with you that cobalt is coming to Xbox
as a console exclusive this October
here's the first look at cobalt for Xbox
world premiere